منذ الايام الاولى من الحرب كان وقوف
الولايات المتحده مع اوكرانيا واضحا دعم
عسكري واستخبارات وسياسي واقتصاد لكن دون
الدخول في مواجهه مباشره مع موسكو لم ياتي
الدعم المذكور دفعه واحده واقتصر في
البدايه على دعم عسكري بقيمه 350 مليون
دولار متضملا وقتها مضادات للدروع واسلحه
خفيفه انتهى المطاف بدعم بلغ حتى يومنا
هذا اكثر من سته وعشرين مليار دولار
والحديث بات يشمل دبابات ابرامز وصواريخ
طويله المدى ومنظومات باتريوت وهايمارس في
الشق الاقتصاد الضاغط على روسيا كانت
العقوبات التي تحاول تضييق الخناق على
روسيا وتطورت الى حد سمحت في واشنطن باول
عمليه نقل لاصول مصادره تتبع جهات روسيه
وبتحويلها الى اوكرانيا
سياسيا كانت هناك زيارات متلاحقه بدلا من
وزيري الخارجيه والدفاع ورئيسه مجلس
النواب السابق ناصر بيلوسي واحدثها دون شك
زياره الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
قادت واشنطن
السياسي وتوحيد الجبه الغربيه في كثير من
المراحل في وجه روسيا ودعما لاوكرانيا وقد
كان مؤتمر الدعم في قاعده رامشتاين
الالمانيه الاكبر وقد شاركت فيه اربعون
دوله بدعوه امريكيه
[موسيقى]